as we've been reporting today marks the
50th anniversary of the assassination of
dr. Martin Luther King jr. this morning
we're sharing the little-known story of
a meeting at the Lorraine Motel
two weeks before King's death he met
college students who were part of a
choir we return now to our special
correspondent James Brown in Memphis
with the encounter that had a lasting
impact on the young singers JB John
indeed it did and Gayle and bianna
you'll love this one as well on the
night of March 18th 1968 two weeks
before he will be killed and exhausted
dr. Martin Luther King jr. returned here
to the Lorraine Motel in Memphis after a
long day of organizing on behalf of the
city's striking sanitation workers now
despite his fatigue King pressed on with
planning meetings late into the evening
but he did accept an invitation of a
choir from the historically black
college Prairie View A&M University to
sing for him crammed into a small
conference room the Prairie View A&M
University acapella concert choir sang
for the iconic civil rights leader the
moment was captured by a filmmaker
following King they were a bit nervous
but confident and they delivered we were
able to do the spirituals the classical
music the anthems and that's where you
came in place what we say here in
Memphis so how did this private meeting
in 1968 come to be good to see you sir
we brought six members of the choir back
to the Lorraine Motel which is now the
National Civil Rights Museum to
reminisce about that night 50 years ago
I don't know that sign coming in
sign has always stuck I live in mind my
name is Judy Lusk I was at Prairie View
in 68 and 69 I'm a soprano Richard burns
I'm a bass I was there from 1964 until
1968 they told me you were a tenor Tom
Jones was a sophomore bass Ernestine
where Odom was a freshman soprano Bob
Duncan's was a senior base and Joe Barry
a sophomore baritone in 1968 while on
tour the choir stopped in Memphis so
their bus driver could rest they checked
into the black-owned Lorraine Motel what
do you remember about your trip here to
Memphis the first morning that we woke
up at Lorraine me and another choir
member walking down the street and then
we noticed that the garbage cans were
stacked to three or four high and we
kept thinking boy Memphis sure is a
filthy city and at that time we didn't
realize that the garbage strike was
taking place the Memphis sanitation
workers were on strike for a month
fed up with low wages and dangerous work
conditions they adopted a simple mantra
I am a man dr. Martin Luther King jr.
was in town to support the strike as
part of his Poor People's Campaign he
and his staff also stayed at the
Lorraine how many of you knew by his
show of hands that dr. King was staying
here but their choir director did dr. H
Edison Anderson implored dr. King's
staff to allow his choir to sing for
them the opportunity came around
midnight after King came back from
giving an evening speech the first call
came out to me from dr. Anderson you
know dr. King is back that's getting
ready to say it'll have to dress don't
get dressed come on what were your
thoughts as you walked into the room it
was just an hour of being in the room
with dr. King and I think the thing that
put a gleam in our eyes and and
everything was to know and to wake
everybody up to know that we were going
to
now for dr. king I love we went on it
was quiet because we you know dr. King
lit seen on TV this is the man that did
the I have a dream speech we are in the
room with with that same person my thing
was I was trying to find my pitch who
spatted find my key and they all did
find their key singing Alleluia by
Randall Thompson to perfection
[Music]
just over two weeks later the tragic
news dr. Martin Luther King the apostle
of non-violence and the civil rights
movement has been shot to death in
Memphis Tennessee King was killed at the
Lorraine Motel I just remember thinking
how sad how sad for the movement that he
had been building you know what are we
gonna do at this point I was angry
because they had just killed my hero I
mean this is the man who was giving his
life to liberating a whole race of
people ironically the same photographer
who filmed the choir singing for King
also took the memorable photo of a slain
King yeah we were singing Hallelujah
which is the highest praise that you can
give to God and he was just overwhelmed
with it I would like two people to know
that per view an Ian cappella choir was
one of the last choirs that sang for
Martin Luther King that we were a part
of the Martin Luther King movement and
it was a very historic night for for all
of us and their voices are still as
uplifting today as in 1968
[Music]
Dail John and Beyond on Monday the six
choir members along with a larger alumni
group from Prairie View am performed at
the canons Center for the Performing
Arts right here in Memphis in a symphony
concert to honor dr. King's memory and
of course the sanitation workers for
whom dr. King came here to fight and
they received a standing ovation for
their rendition of Hallelujah and as I
throw it back to you guys
John Gayle and beyond I promise when I
come out to do a story for you guys
again I will learn to laugh with my
tongue in my mouth as opposed to letting
it that was a nice moment and I'm so
glad you asked them to sing again James
because I was wondering can they still
sing and they can I'm so glad you did
that I would have been more polite that
was actually producer Alvin Patrick so
I'm going to put the blame on him Thank
You Alvin Patrick that was a very nice
touch nicely done what insight from that
choir director to know that dr. King was
there right and to see the pictures of
dr. King you know he wants when he was
in Berlin he once talked about music and
he says it strengthens us with its sweet
rhythms when courage begins to fail it
calms us with rich harmonies when
spirits were down you see him being
affected by that music in those words
even at midnight as tired as he was he
was moved what a great story